our little yellow drawers took us back
in time it's halloween night 1985.
welcome to our 80s preteen bedroom i
just watched flashdance last night what
did you watch uh i watched uh footloose
and uh terms of endearment i'm still
crying that's what i call a double
feature
um
drew do you know what our bedroom is
missing well it's missing two best
friends who like to stay up late
watching movies trying on makeup and
sharing some gossip and playing games
that's what we need up in here
[Applause]
i mean we're best friends and we are
looking for best friends in the 80s um
sandra and ida where are you
[Applause]
oh my god this is so fun oh my
it's true i was like actually hanging
out with madonna in these days i'm not
kidding i was in the same club she was
but what were you guys doing in the 80s
what were you doing halloween night 1985
probably dressed like you at a party
yes yes or maybe all black white wasn't
my thing sorry oh it's not the um most
flattering of power
that's for sure like what was your life
well i think we were teenagers and it
was all about boys and trying to find
the right boy who had that perfect look
maybe like billy maybe like boy george
maybe like duran duran oh my god i
wanted to marry every member of duran
duran i had theirs
[Applause]
how long have you guys been friends
literally since like the early 80s
so you were like dressed like this
gossiping in a bedroom just like
yeah yeah and this
we we had a bit oh yeah we have to have
a dance party
[Applause]
this is exactly what we were doing
i love it
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
um from our decade in a little game of
80s hearts rob trivia
okay the first question that we're
playing for is worth a hundred dollars
ready okay
i this is a true story i shared my first
slow dance with 80s heartthrob emilio
estevez um and his uh brother charlie
sheen um screamed dance mother you know
what i am platoon and
i'm just wondering um what was charlie
sheen and um emilio estevez's father's
name i i i think we know it yeah right
martin jean yeah
thank you
thank you thank you
question number two
is worth two hundred dollars oh my god
okay our 80s had two major heartthrobs
named cory one was a goonie and the
other had a license to drive
name the two corys
oh boy
corey feldman yeah that's one
cory haim
somebody was
on point in the eighties okay question
number three we're three hundred dollars
we could wax on forever about this 80s
heartthrob ralph macchio who stepped
back into that role that made him famous
for a netflix show in 2018 that is still
going strong
oh gosh this is spell ralph macchio's
last name
well you know you had better grades okay
you went you honestly think about it you
went to a better high school you went to
a better college you know all right do
you know how to spell machio
i do
okay
c
c
h
[Applause]
paid off okay are you ready for question
number four worth four hundred dollars
oh boy
pictured here is the car jake ryan drove
in 1984 16
candles what kind of car is it
i i i mustang okay fine mustang final
answer unfortunately not it was a poor
shot
[Applause]
oh
okay
um okay that's okay though because we
have one more question the last question
is for a whopping 1400 for a total of
two thousand oh my gosh
[Applause]
seconds to okay
this 80s thirst trap and tell us who
this heart prob is
oh he life was a nightmare for him oh i
know that joe i know that job wait wait
wait wait wait i don't even see anything
my arm is his job
on my hair forever
[Applause]
anybody i'd rather kick it in our
pre-teen bedroom with more than you guys
[Applause]
[Music]